hi everyone
in today's lecture we're going to talk
about attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder also known as ADHD
I want to start by telling you about a
boy named Gary
is 10 years old and Exhibits a variety
of problem behaviors both at school and
at home
on the bus to and from school he can't
seem to sit still and often switches
from seat to seat so we can talk to all
of his friends
his backpack is disorganized and many
times he forgets to do his homework
he has a hard time staying on task in
the classroom and he'll click his pen
during class which is distracting to
both his classmates and his teacher
he continues to do so even when he's
asked to stop
he also gets yelled at a lot by his
teachers throughout the day for not
paying attention
when he gets home from school Gary is
supposed to complete his choice in
chores and homework however he often
struggles with both remembering this
information and following through with
it
this gets him in trouble with his
parents who often complain that no
matter what they do or say Gary's
Behavior doesn't seem to change
Gary also tells his parents that he's
doing pretty well in school but when
they talk to his teachers they find that
he exaggerates a bit
his parents have also noticed that
transitions are difficult for Gary and
that it's nearly impossible to do
anything relaxing with him
he has trouble sustaining attention even
for short periods of time so even
watching TV makes him Restless
although many of these behaviors can be
seen in all children during different
periods of their lives
in children with ADHD these behaviors
are constant and resistant to change
creating significant problems both at
home and in school
these problems even play out in simple
day-to-day activities
Gary was diagnosed with a mild form of
ADHD at age six
and exhibit symptoms that are very
common among children with this disorder
but what else exactly do we know about
ADHD
ADHD affects approximately 2.2 percent
of all children worldwide with males
receiving a diagnosis more frequently
than females
and more than 75 percent of diagnosed
children continue to exhibit significant
problems into adulthood
One symptom hyperactivity generally
improves during the teenage years but
other symptoms such as inattention
disorganization and poor impulse control
continue into adulthood
individuals with ADHD can be very
successful in life
however without identification and
proper treatment
the disorder can have serious
consequences including School failure
family stress and disruption depression
relationship problems substance abuse
delinquency accidental injuries and
trouble maintaining a job
so early diagnosis and treatment are
extremely important contributors to
success later on
Medical Science first documented
children exhibiting inattentiveness
impulsivity and hyperactivity Back In
1902
since that time this group of symptoms
has been given numerous names including
minimal brain dysfunction
hyperkinetic reaction of childhood and
attention deficit disorder with or
without hyperactivity
the most current version of the
diagnostic and statistical manual for
mental disorders DSM-5 breaks ADHD into
three different categories
the first category is inattention
note that in previous versions of the
DSM this was listed as a separate
disorder known as ADD attention deficit
disorder
add now falls under the larger umbrella
of ADHD
people with ADD have difficulty with
sustained attention
some of the behaviors they might exhibit
include needing things to be repeated
multiple times before fully
understanding them
or appearing spaced out when someone is
talking to them
they also may be forgetful needing
reminders throughout the day to complete
daily tasks like chores
they may also lose things like homework
assignments books keys and so on
and maybe easily distracted by
extraneous stimuli
so for example
if you're trying to have a conversation
with someone who has ADD and the
television is on in the background
they may become easily distracted by the
TV
those with ADD may also have trouble
with organization exhibiting poor time
management skills failing to meet
deadlines or failing to keep belongings
organized
do you recognize any of these symptoms
in our opening description of Gary
yes right
remember Gary would do things like
forget to do his homework and chores
after school keep a disorganized
backpack and so on
so he definitely exhibited symptoms of
an attention
to be diagnosed with this form of ADHD
a person must exhibit several of these
symptoms for a period of at least six
months
the symptoms must be inconsistent with
their developmental level
and they must negatively impact the
person's social and or academic
activities
the second category of ADHD is called
hyperactive and impulsive
to be diagnosed with this type of ADHD
the person must also exhibit symptoms
for at least six months or longer and
the symptoms must negatively impact
their life
individuals with this type of ADHD May
exhibit symptoms such as the inability
to sit still or a tendency to fidget
with their hands or feet
they might also be unable to engage in
leisure activities
quietly or talk excessively
in addition they might appear to be
always on the go
they may have difficulty waiting their
turn they may interrupt others when they
are engaged in conversation or
activities and they may blurt out
answers before a question has been
completed
Gary exhibited some of these symptoms
too
remember how he would click his pen
during class or be restless when
watching television
he definitely showed symptoms of
hyperactivity and impulsiveness
the third and final category of ADHD is
a combined presentation of the first two
types in this case a person would show
symptoms of inattention as well as
symptoms of hyperactivity and
impulsivity
this is the type of ADHD Gary was
diagnosed with
in addition to identifying the specific
type of ADHD a person exhibits
criteria put forth by the DSM-5 also
require professionals who diagnose ADHD
to include the severity of the disorder
as either mild moderate or severe
someone with mild ADHD would only
exhibit a few of the symptoms specified
in the DSM and symptoms would only
result in minor impairments in the
individual's social school or work
settings
at the severe level the individual with
ADHD would exhibit many symptoms beyond
the number needed to make the diagnosis
with several beings severe or associated
with marked impairments in Social school
or work settings
someone with moderate ADHD would have
symptoms or functional impairment that
fall between the mild and the severe
levels
there is no single test to diagnose ADHD
rather a comprehensive evaluation is
necessary to establish a diagnosis rule
out other causes and determine the
presence or absence of coexisting
conditions
such an evaluation requires time and
effort and should include a careful
history and a clinical assessment of the
individual's academic social and
emotional functioning as well as their
developmental level
to receive a diagnosis of ADHD a
person's symptoms must be present before
the age of 12.
adults who exhibit symptoms associated
with ADHD but never received an official
diagnosis as children can still be
diagnosed though if they are able to
demonstrate that they first experience
symptoms before they were 12.
several types of professionals can
diagnose ADHD including clinical
psychologists clinical social workers
nurse practitioners neurologists
psychiatrists and pediatricians
regardless of who does the evaluation
the use of DSM-5 diagnostic criteria for
ADHD is necessary to obtain an accurate
diagnosis
keep in mind though that sometimes
individuals can have more than one
diagnosis which complicates matters so
for example a child might be diagnosed
with ADHD and depression
or ADHD and a learning disability
other times individuals who have ADHD
are misdiagnosed because symptoms of
ADHD can overlap with those of other
disorders
some of the most common misdiagnoses
include conduct disorders anxiety
depression Tourette's Syndrome substance
abuse and autism spectrum disorders
this is one reason why it is important
to not diagnose someone at first glance
but to examine them over time and at
different time periods to see how their
symptoms develop and change
rushing to obtain a diagnosis is not
beneficial to anyone and can in fact
make the situation worse
although nobody really knows what causes
ADHD
researchers have been able to identify
some potential risk factors associated
with its development
most likely ADHD results from a
combination of factors that interact
with and influence one another
trying to separate out these factors to
determine how they contribute to the
onset of a disorder is a nearly
impossible task
at best we can only speculate as to what
factors may lead to the onset of a
disorder
even then though we don't know whether
it is the factors themselves that
contribute to the cause of the disorder
or whether there are secondary hidden
factors that we are failing to consider
here's an example
did you know that there is a positive
relationship or correlation between the
amount of ice cream consumed and the
number of violent crimes that are
committed
Yep they're related as one increases the
other increases
does one really influence the other
though
or is there some secondary hidden factor
that we are failing to take into account
here
what about the heat of Summer
when it's hot out
people tend to eat more ice cream
and believe it or not the number of
violent crimes increases during the hot
summer months
you see what I mean
we need to be very careful when we start
talking about factors and whether or not
they contribute to the causes of a
disorder like ADHD
keeping this in mind let's examine some
factors that might be related to ADHD
it's believed that both genetic and
environmental factors contribute to the
onset of ADHD
though many candidate genes have been
examined unfortunately none of them
currently have any predictive value nor
do they highlight any novel biological
mechanisms
and so the search continues
we do however see an increased incidence
of ADHD with biological relatives
so it's likely that genetic factors
contribute to the onset of the disorder
more than likely though genetic factors
in and of themselves do not cause ADHD
instead environmental risk factors
trigger certain genes which then leads
to the onset of the disorder
so what are some of these environmental
risk factors
one category is prenatal and perinatal
risk factors including such things as
maternal smoking maternal substance
abuse including alcohol maternal stress
the baby being born with a low birth
weight or premature birth
though these factors have not been
scientifically shown to cause ADHD
they may be one piece of a larger puzzle
that contributes to its development
a second category involves a person's
exposure to environmental toxins
the most widely studied toxins in this
regard include organophosphate
pesticides bifanils and Lead
although these are viewed as potential
risks it is unclear for how long or at
what developmental period the exposure
needs to take place to maximize this
risk
a third category is dietary factors
these include things like nutritional
deficiencies such as zinc magnesium and
polyunsaturated fatty acids nutritional
surpluses like artificial food colorings
and foods low or high in immunoglobulin
G
the final category is psychosocial
adversity and includes things such as
family dysfunction and low socioeconomic
status
conflict including parent-child
hostility and severe early deprivation
none of these environmental factors have
been shown to be causal
so we cannot say for example that
exposure to lead causes ADHD
rather we can only say that exposure to
lead could potentially increase a
person's risk of getting ADHD because a
correlation has been found between the
two factors
a variety of neuropsychological deficits
have been tied to ADHD but not everyone
with a disorder exhibits them
some individuals display a single
deficit some multiple deficits and still
others none at all
so there is a huge range of individual
variability
I'm going to focus here on some of the
neuropsychological deficits that seem to
be fairly common across multiple
individuals with ADHD
these include impulsivity and problems
with planning inattention
hyperactivity problems modulating
gratification and trouble with emotional
regulation
let's look at these one at a time
starting with impulsivity and problems
with planning
impulsiveness directly leads to problems
with planning
if you think about it planning requires
the ability to inhibit an action while
thinking through the best ways to obtain
a goal and then executing and monitoring
that plan
here's an example let's say I wanted to
go outside and do some yard work let's
say pull some weeds
if I were acting on impulse I might just
go outside and start pulling weeds at
various locations throughout my yard
without putting on sunscreen first
without the proper closer gloves
and without a plan to make sure my time
spent outside is efficient
if I resist this impulsivity however I
can think through the best method by
which to accomplish this task
in this case I would dress properly put
on sunscreen gather my gardening tools
and move methodically through the yard
as I weed
I would also be able to Monitor and
change my plan if necessary
for example if it started raining I
could delay my yard work or perhaps work
in a region that is not affected much by
the rain
in other words I could shift my thinking
about my plan and I could be cognitively
flexible when it comes to executing that
plan
someone with ADHD would have great
difficulty doing this
neuropsychological deficit is
inattention
in particular difficulty with sustained
attention
if I asked you to sit and work on a
puzzle for 30 minutes straight without
stopping
could you do it
if so you are able to maintain sustained
attention on a task
if however you keep needing to get up
and walk around you fidget in your seat
you Daydream and you can't seem to stay
on task then you might have problems
with sustained attention
this type of deficit also relates to our
ability to function efficiently if you
can't stay on task it will take you
longer to get things done
what about hyperactivity
this is when someone is excessively
restless and overactive someone who
fidgets quite a bit
this obviously can lead to issues trying
to complete tasks in a timely manner
a fourth deficit involves problems
modulating gratification
what in the world does that mean
it means that individuals with ADHD are
driven toward immediate frequent
predictable and meaningful forms of
gratification
at the same time they have great
difficulty working toward a long-term
goal
if for example a child with ADHD really
wants to buy a toy that costs twenty
dollars
and I give them ten dollars with a
promise that I will give them another
ten dollars in a week so that they can
buy the 20 toy
they would more than likely spend the
ten dollars right away to get the
immediate reward rather than wait a week
for me to give them another ten dollars
this holds true even in older children
with ADHD who have learned the value of
money and the benefits that come from
saving it
One Way researchers have examined
delayed gratification in children is
through the famous marshmallow
experiment first conducted at Stanford
in the 1970s
here children are offered a choice of
receiving one marshmallow immediately or
two marshmallows if they wait 15 minutes
during the wait time the single
marshmallow is placed in front of the
child on a table and the researcher
leaves the room
children who can delay their
gratification to receive the two
marshmallows have been found to distract
themselves by refusing to look at the
marshmallow singing laying their head
down on the table Etc
children with ADHD have a lot of
difficulty averting their attention away
from the treat and thus usually fail the
test
the final deficit relates to emotional
regulation or lack thereof
individuals with ADHD appear to be on a
roller coaster ride of emotions when
they are happy they are so happy that it
disrupts the people around them
when they are unhappy they are so
unhappy that people are equally
disrupted they operate at the extremes
often going from one to the other
if you think about it these
neuropsychological abilities affect
multiple aspects of Our Lives whether it
be family social academic or vocational
when these abilities are intact we
perform in a consistent predictable
independent and efficient manner
failure to use and develop these
abilities however leads to unpredictable
behavior and inconsistency which affects
every aspect of Our Lives
researchers have shown through a variety
of studies that multiple areas and
Pathways in the brain are affected by
ADHD
some of the major brain areas involved
include the frontal lobes basal ganglia
system and the cerebellum
reductions in cortical volume have been
identified in these regions
and these brain areas also form brain
circuits so connections of neurons from
different brain regions that subserve
particular brain functions
four of these circuits have been
implicated in the neuropathology
underlying ADHD
the first is called the fronto striate
thalamic circuit
this circuit has bi-directional
interconnections between the prefrontal
and parietal cortices the basal ganglia
system and various nuclei in the
thalamus
it's believed that this circuit mediates
abilities such as working memory
response inhibition and sustained
attention
the second circuit called the cortico
cerebellar circuit focuses on the
cerebellum and its projections to the
prefrontal cortex singular gyrus and
some parietal regions this circuit is
involved with analyzing information
about the temporal structure of the
environment
damage to the Circuit would result in
errors related to time estimation
such as how long we think it is going to
take us to do something and perception
the third circuit involves connections
between the ventral portion of the
striatum and the basal ganglia system
and the orbital frontal cortex in the
frontal lobes
it's believed that damage to this
circuit is associated with an inversion
to delayed reinforcement
in other words people who have damage to
this circuit will accept an immediate
reward but not a delayed one
think back to the example where the
child spent a small amount of money
right away rather than saving it to buy
something more expensive
the last circuit involves connections
between the amygdala the prefrontal
cortex and the orbital frontal cortex
this circuit is believed to be involved
in the regulation of our emotions
damage to this circuit could result in
the roller coaster ride of emotions
often noted in individuals with ADHD
there are four basic categories of
treatment for people with ADHD
medication
therapy
Education and Training and school-based
programs
keep in mind that many individuals
benefit benefit from involvement in all
four of these categories at the same
time
let's start by looking at medication
the first line of treatment medication
wise for individuals with ADHD is
stimulants
you might be thinking why would anyone
give a stimulant to someone who is
hyperactive
believe it or not they are pretty
effective in reducing hyperactivity and
impulsivity and improving one's ability
to focus work and learn
but how
stimulants tend to increase the
neurotransmitter dopamine which
contributes to the ability of our
frontal lobes to function properly
commonly prescribed stimulants include
Ritalin Concerta vivance and Adderall
although there are others
if a person with ADHD has difficulty
taking stimulants maybe they cause
bothersome side effects
non-stimulants may be a helpful
alternative
in general these medications take longer
to start working than stimulants but
have been shown to improve focus
attention and impulsivity in a person
with ADHD either by boosting the
neurotransmitter norepinephrine as the
drug addamoxetine does or by stimulating
activity in adrenergic receptors as is
the case with the drug guanfacine
keep in mind that there are many
different types and brands of
medications each with their own
potential side effects and benefits
sometimes different medications
different dosages or even different
combinations of medications are needed
to find out what works best for each
individual
obviously a person would need to be
closely monitored by their prescribing
doctor to determine this
a second category of potential treatment
is behavioral therapy
research suggests that behavioral
therapy works best by helping patients
and their families learn how to better
cope with daily challenges and struggles
rather than directly changing ADHD
symptoms per se
for example for children and teens the
therapist might work with parents and
teachers to help the individual keep a
routine organize items and reward them
when they are successful at doing these
things
for adults therapists might provide them
with tools to help organize their life
keep routines and break large tasks into
smaller more manageable ones
this idea of teaching families and
teachers how to help children with ADHD
is also relevant to the next category
Education and Training
research shows that in order to reach
their full potential and succeed
children and adults with ADHD need
guidance and support from their families
and their teachers
Education and Training includes one
teaching parents the skills they need to
encourage and reward positive behaviors
in their children
two sharing stress management techniques
with parents so they can deal better
with their own frustrations and by
extension with their child's Behavior
and three having parents and families
join support groups so they can connect
with others who are dealing with similar
situations
the last category is school-based
programs
some schools offer special education
services to children with aedhd who
qualify
here education Specialists can help make
changes to classroom and homework
assignments in order to help the child
succeed
In Sum medication as well as a variety
of Support Services to help not only the
person with ADHD but also their families
are known to benefit individuals with
ADHD and maximize their best chances for
success
we've covered quite a bit in this
lecture
and I hope you now have a better
understanding of ADHD
join us in our next lecture as we
examine another disorder that is
frequently diagnosed in childhood
developmental dyslexia
bye for now